si la plupart des chiens peuvent être de
compagnie les lévriers barzoï était à
l'origine dressé pour la chasse au loup
dans les steppes de russie et si
aujourd'hui le leur a remplacé le loup
la course de vitesse est resté dans
leurs gènes très impatient sait ce qui
l'attend depuis ce matin son tour arrive
pour lui c'est un lapin qui au bout du
câble est donc ce sont des chiens de
chasse et des lévriers et donc bah c'est
sa passion chasser courir après le leur
fait plaisir de les voir courir et il
s'éclate
donc on s'éclate mes chiens et moi on
s'éclate c'est une journée de bonheur
pour nous en plus ce cocktail soleil
c'est encore mieux
la chasse avec lévriers est interdite en
france depuis 1844 cpvl poursuite à vue
sur leurre permettent donc aux éleveurs
comme aux particuliers d'aidé à la
conservation de leurs instincts de
poursuite des courses analysées par un
juge aussi professionnel que passionné
le plaisir de voir ce mouvement cette
puissance cette élégance et cette
puissance réuni quoi donc
et puis bon on va moi j'ai été bercé
dedans parce que moi ça fait que
quarante deux ans que j'ai des lévriers
mais ma mère avait déjà des lévriers
donc je finis je suis né de juillet donc
donc j'aurais dû j'aurai du mal à avoir
d'autres races est bon il ya des chiens
bon bah il en faut pour tous les goûts
mais il ya tous les genres et puis bon
ben moi de ses 7 grâce cette puissance
qui s'en dégage
pour les amateurs de lévriers ou les
curieux un concours de beauté et de
course se déroulera en indre et loire à
ligueil les 9 et 10 mai prochains